hi adobe creative educators welcome back
to our adobe creative educator show
we're very excited to be here with you
today and have some very incredible
guests that are joining us but if you're
just joining us from facebook youtube or
twitter please post in the chat what
you're um teaching where you're joining
us from we'd love to get to know a
little bit more about you and i see some
already some folks joining in and we
have
um tarek joining us from um egypt
welcome
and we have jessica joining us from
gwinnett county jessica i know we just
did an event earlier today so it's
really great to see you um joining us so
again this is a live show so you do have
the opportunity to ask questions live
and join uh with other educators from
our international adobe creative
educator program
but for those i haven't had the pleasure
of meeting i'm clara i manage our
educator community programs here at
adobe and as i mentioned this is a very
special edition of our adobe creative
educator show
um so as you know every month we're
focusing on a different theme here and
have challenges throughout the year for
you to create remixable templates with
your students and um with other
educators and this month our theme is
cultivating creative confidence with
your students and now we know especially
in the month of april during testing
season um this is something that is
prevalent in all classrooms um around
the country within the us
and even around the world
and so we're thrilled today to be joined
by sal khan of khan academy i'm the ceo
of khan academy and you're going to be
hearing from him his perspectives and
also have the opportunity to ask some
questions live in the chat um but
without further ado i'm gonna bring sal
on so sal thank you so much for joining
us today how are you
i'm doing well thanks for having me
claire
we're so excited to have you on the show
and for the vast majority of our
audience you likely need no introduction
um but just to kick us off could you
please introduce a little bit more about
yourself and share more about your
current mission at khan academy and how
it's evolved since you founded it 14
years ago
sure uh so sal khan founder and ceo of
khan academy uh which as as you
introduced or as many people know we're
a not-for-profit organization with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and as you
mentioned it started over actually
14 years ago 14 years ago is actually
when we did set up as a not-for-profit
but it started back in 2004 as a
tutoring project
where i wasn't i was an analyst at a
hedge fund and i was i started tutoring
one family member remotely i was in
boston she was in new orleans uh that
went well it was helping her i became
what i call a tiger cousin i started
tutoring more cousins uh before i knew
it free word spread in my family that
free tutoring was going on and i was
tutoring 10 or 15 cousins and i saw
patterns that
the reason why they were oftentimes
struggling was because they just had
gaps in their knowledge so i started
writing software for them my original
background was in software so i did this
as a hobby for them to get as much
practice as they want and then a friend
suggested that i make videos to
supplement the software i thought it was
a silly idea at first but i gave it a
shot and those videos also took on a
life of their own
and uh by 2008 is when i when i formally
incorporated khan academy and set it up
as a not-for-profit you know you fast
forward to today what started with a
handful of cousins is now
130 million registered users about 30
million folks come
every month to the platform we're in 50
languages
around the world
but our mission free world-class
education for anyone anywhere is still
the same mission and our vision is can
we offer all of the core academic
content from pre-k through the core of
college for anyone in the world everyone
in the world and all the world's major
languages can can we do it in a way that
really meets students where they are and
so these are principles i'm happy to
talk more about it of personalization
empowering students meeting them where
they are mastery learning which is
always having the opportunity incentive
to improve where you are instead of just
getting a c and moving on keep working
on it so that you can you can get to a
90 or or 100
and the third pillar of our vision is
how can we make that learning translate
into real opportunity getting into
college you get a job uh what whatever
it might be uh so come a long way since
those early days uh but still a long way
to go we we aspire
to empower billions hopefully over time
thank you so much for sharing that
background and i know there's a lot of
educators in our international community
that are that are using khan academy
and i'm just popping over here to seeing
some of the the chat we have benjamin
joining us from england uh rachel
joining us from texas
and tim hi tim from from new york says
i'm excited to learn more about khan
academy today have some amazing
resources so we're looking forward and
to diving more into that and rebecca
who's going to be uh joining us here in
a moment live says i love the tiger
cousin role so it's great to hear those
um origins of khan academy that we that
we know and love um here in the
international educator community
um but we also have another um guest
joining us today
and so i'm gonna bring him on here in a
moment
hey ben how's it going hello there good
to be here
so ben is here on our team and also our
you know director of education but then
leads an incredible team of evangelists
and community members and community
leaders here at adobe and ben you're
quite the legend
in your experience in education
including your tenure at adobe um so can
you share a little bit more about
yourself and your background
uh sure i'm not sure about legend but
thank you uh yeah i have a wonderful
team uh here at adobe we focus on
helping
k-12 educators worldwide inject
creativity in the classroom in very
meaningful ways
i am an educator myself i've been
teaching for over 30 years
i'm also an author i've written 40 plus
books that have taught coding to over a
million people
and actually more relevant to our topic
today my most recent book
uses game coding to introduce creative
thinking and creative problem solving
for middle and high school students
so that's what we do we spend a lot of
time thinking about creativity and how
to help k-12 teachers and it's a
pleasure to be here
thank you for joining us ben and sal i
know we have a great conversation ahead
of us in particular focusing on mastery
learning and creative confidence in the
classroom um
but sal in particular for for khan
academy how do you see educators um
in the community cultivating a creative
confidence in their students
well
you you know
i i think creativity can only happen
when there's space for it
um and so
it i think it's important and i think
about this as a parent as well um
you know when i was a kid uh my family
didn't have a lot of resources and so
like i was bored a lot and but that
boredom you know i was like okay there's
some pencil there's some paper i guess
i'm gonna do something i used to draw a
lot and you know at the time i remember
i used to envy the kids who could go to
these fancy summer camps and do this and
do that and and you know and and and
those things can be very nice
but i i now realize in my own childhood
there was something nice about that
boredom fostering creativity and making
you know you you learn to make things as
opposed to kind of being directed always
on what you should do
so i think about this as a parent now
because you know i now do have the
resources and my kids probably are
getting over scheduled and i'm like oh
am i squeezing out the time for some of
their creativity um and i also you know
sometimes in classrooms
i think teachers can feel
a burden on them to like hey i got to
make sure that every
every second of this classroom is
productive for my students and that's
that's a good
instinct although sometimes i think it
is nice to create some you need some
guardrails for the students and some
objectives for them but then give them a
little bit of space give them a little
bit of space to potentially fail uh to
have a larger variance in what they
might produce
and i think those are the areas where uh
you can let that creativity which i
think all human beings have it's a but
it can atrophy if it's not given enough
space and enough time and obviously it
can happen at every every level you know
a lot of people think of creativity they
think of
an artist splashing paint on a canvas or
something like that that's obviously one
form of creativity but creativity can
even happen
as you know
when you're when you're looking at an
equation and
kind of the the non-creative form of of
processing the equation is all right i
just plug numbers into it and it gives
me an answer the creative form is like
what does this mean how does this
connect to other things can i draw
connections with it can i manipulate it
to have it express in new ways that tell
me other things about the universe that
can connect to other ideas so i think it
can happen in anything but you need some
some time and space um for it
absolutely and i'm seeing here in the
chat to educators um really resonating
with their own experiences and sal i
love how you mentioned
how creativity is not just the arts and
i think that's sometimes the
misconception that we see in schools but
it's that whole making connections and
what does the creative thinking process
look like in math it looked like in
english language arts and sciences and
um one of the things that we see in our
community and i know in khan academy as
well is that they're educators from all
different subject areas so as you said
just providing that space and that
opportunity for students to have that
freedom is is so powerful
um and ben anything to add to that in
terms of you know what you've been
seeing um at adobe
yeah so um i echo everything sal said
and you know we need to reach students
and educators and when it comes to to
reaching students honestly
not much is needed it's get out of the
way
give them room to play give them the
latitude to experiment and fail and give
them license to iterate uh permission to
discover find their own voice that's
actually the easy part
uh the trickier part we find are the
teachers themselves
they are overwhelmed they have often
strict guidelines and constraints that
they have to adhere to and the last
thing we ever want to do is give them
more work that's
unrealistic it's also frankly
disrespectful and so we spend a lot of
time working with educators to help them
understand how to meaningfully
inject creativity in every subject as
you just noted in a very relevant way
you know we have the tools we think we
have the best tools for them to be using
we have great content on our education
exchange including all the materials uh
created in partnership with khan academy
and so we work with school districts and
leads with trainers
and our focus is to help them understand
the how how to be
less prescriptive which sal just alluded
to how to rethink assignments how to
rethink the balance of lecturing versus
doing how to rethink students taking
agency finding their own path
and we do this with training with
mentoring with
professional development uh
participation in our adobe creative
educator community
and all of these the goal of all these
programs is really to empower educators
with the confidence
to let the students do what they'll
naturally do best
and i know a part of that ben as you
mentioned are the tools and i know we'll
dive into some of the the tools that are
um offered and possible for educators
later but but absolutely and kind of
looking at across all subject areas you
know providing the freedom providing the
space for them to be creative and this
is again so powerful
and i'm seeing um some some comments in
the chat here
and tim says i love giving students and
myself some free time and space boredom
can be a terrific breeding ground um for
creativity and imagination and so i
think really and uh brought that um well
together and i see cuban nice to see you
joining us from johannesburg in south
africa
and
marilyn also says appreciate the
sensitivity in regards to teachers um so
thank you they're from from maryland
but i know we've touched on this a
little bit and in your introduction um
sal
but when it comes to um thinking about
creative confidence
and then an overlap between mastery
mindset and creativity how do those all
um you know
come into play together and especially
during april during testing season how
can educators really approach these
three pieces together of mastery mindset
and creativity
and i'll add another dimension of growth
mindset uh to to that you know it's very
in vogue uh these days to talk about the
growth mindset there's obviously a lot
of great research from folks like
carolyn dweck carol dweck and you know
angela duckworth and other folks uh and
it's all on this principle that like it
a growth mindset is better um and and
it's it's a mindset in which
you don't stigmatize failure you realize
that if you if you didn't succeed that's
actually and if you reflect on it that's
actually where you're going to grow the
most and if you have a you know
stick-to-itiveness a greater
perseverance and you keep working on it
so that you can get to a point of
fluency or mastery that that is how
you're going to improve the most in
almost any in any in any domain
mastery learning is
how that gets implemented in an academic
setting in my in my point of view as i
hinted at in our traditional model a
student gets an 80 on a test and
they kind of you mark that down in their
grade book and the student says i guess
i'm a c student
and
one that that probably creates a fixed
mindset on one level because you're not
even telling the student hey
why don't you give another shot at it
get better at it this isn't a bad thing
that you got some questions wrong those
are opportunities to learn
but also then those gaps persist and
which is i think particularly harmful in
stem subjects i think it's harmful in
all subjects but if you if you only
understood how to divide decimals 80
percent well now all of a sudden the
whole classroom is doing uh equations
with decimals or doing you know
some more decimal dividing decimal word
problems how are you going to really be
able to master that if you couldn't
understand the more the more fundamental
um the more fundamental idea
and so i think
you
you know mastery which is in my my
definition is always having the
opportunity incentive to improve
your state i think it's important for
developing the the tools
um
so that you can express yourself
creatively
yeah i think if you look at the field of
mathematics the fields of science these
are
these are
clearly creative fields you're trying to
come up with new ways of describing
reality new ways of understanding
reality new ways of
you know engineering new ways of
inventing things
and i think the reason why sometimes
there's a stereotype that it's not is
because
so much time and effort goes behind
building the competencies so that you
can be creative in the space
it's kind of like if we were trying to
be artists but you know for the first 12
years you're just learning to mix paint
and you never get to be the artist or
you're learning to be a dancer but for
the first 12 years you're stretching
and you never get to really express
yourself through dance
and so i'm a big fan of
if
you know the mastery learning's gonna
build those competencies so you feel
that confidence so that when you do
engage on hey why does the krebs circle
work krebs cycle work this way in
biology or
you know what what what is
what are these different forms of an
equation really tell you you need that
fluency in order to be able to dig into
the conversation but then it unlocks an
incredibly um creative one and and i i
the more that we can bring some of what
real mathematicians do what real
scientists do into the classroom all the
better but but i will say you know
there's there's kind of
historically there's been a schism in
with educators where there's been what
you call the progressive educators it's
like yes let's bring this all in to the
classroom tomorrow or right now where
kids are acting as scientists acting as
mathematicians acting as historians and
then you have your traditionalists who
say well no no the kids really need to
have to have their fluency you really
need to be able to solve certain types
of problems
i i generally think it's both um you
really can't activate a lot of the
creative you can't you know the
scientists who are thinking like
scientists have a lot of content
knowledge and have a lot of fluencies
and if they don't they're going to have
trouble thinking like a scientist in a
lot of cases so can you use mastery
learning tools like khan academy other
tools to get that foundation and then
hopefully free up time for more of this
the creative aspects which exist in
every field
absolutely and that whole process of
iteration and having a growth mindset
and continuing to fail along the way is
something
that we've seen just even within design
and and creating different visual um
concepts and communicating um so i know
it's something within our community
we've seen um quite a bit as well
and then um from the adobe side anything
um to add to that in terms of mastery
mastery learning and the growth mindset
yeah
i'll add that um
obviously creativity is a foundational
skill right it's about agency it's about
finding your own voice
uh it's about iteration and
you know
nurturing that creative thinking
nurturing creative problem solving and
creating comments in general
those are are critical to developing a
growth mindset at your own pace which is
literally mastery you know when um i'm a
huge fan of uh sir ken robinson's
definition that creativity
is the process of having original ideas
that have value and in that definition
the word that's most important to me is
original the unique uh the idea that
we're encouraging a child to find their
own path that isn't necessarily exactly
the same as the kids sitting next to him
or her in the classroom and
this is real and meaningful and
impactful and it has recognized
implications both short term and long
term right there's lots of research that
shows the impact short term impact on
education outcomes in the classroom but
it has long-term implications for future
success look i i don't want education to
ever be
solely driven by jobs and hiring trends
right we don't want to be
you know in first grade worrying about
occupation you have 20 years down the
line we want well-rounded students but
at the same time we can't ignore future
opportunities and industry doesn't want
more of the same you never hear a
company saying i love this employee i
want a thousand more exactly the same as
him or her right we want diversity we
want it not just for diversity but also
diverse thoughts diverse problem-solving
diverse thinking diverse backgrounds
diverse voices that's critical
and we have to nurture that and if we
fail to encourage that unique honestly
we're robbing kids of their future and
for us that's what creativity
in the classroom is all about and that
creativity must be nurtured and the
truth is you know tying back to where we
started off
nurturing creativity is truly
encouraging mastery
absolutely and i i know that speaking of
jobs of the future we don't know what a
lot of those physicians will be but what
we do know is if you have a growth
mindset you can think creatively you can
make those connections you can iterate
along the way approach problems from
different angles that's what's going to
be successful and ultimately what
employers are looking for
um
so it and going quickly to the comments
here we do have some um
comments from the chat we have timothy
joining us from canada says
traditionally math has never been
recognized as being creative students
can produce instructional videos with a
creative element based on math
so some ideas to kind of bring in
creativity into the process
um and tim says agreed i think one of
the strengths of online tools is that
they allow that self-paced kind of
personalized individualized
learning
so and then goes on to say great points
um diversity brings value in with
different perspectives and ideas so
again if you're watching live um this is
a live show so go ahead and post in the
chat if you have comments questions it's
a great opportunity to interact with our
speakers live
i will i will add you know on some of
those comments you know i like i love
the idea of making videos obviously i
spend a lot of time doing that
and and and there is you know if
especially matthew actually in any
subject math science humanities one of
the most direct ways of applying
creativity is yeah ask students to make
artifacts explainers videos or even to
tutor each other because if you have to
if you think about it when you have to
tutor someone else it's an incredibly
creative process you have to model their
mind and then think about creative
pathways that might unlock
uh certain concepts in their mind we
have actually a platform called
schoolhouse.world which is another
not-for-profit which does free tutoring
where people volunteer to tutor other
people so if you that's for 13 years old
and over but another great outlet to
flex creativity in a very direct way
that's great and that's
schoolhouse.world we can go ahead and
put that in the chat
great well um thank you so much for this
um great discussion and we'll get back
to some of these points
but within every live stream we go
through the creative process speaking of
iterating and and going through that
process of define create and reflect so
many adobe creative educators know this
process well um but with that we're
going to actually move on to our create
portion where you're going to have the
opportunity to get hands-on with
creative cloud express and actually
co-create alongside sal khan
our april challenge
so as we move to the crate portion i'm
going to go ahead and bring up my
colleague um rebecca hair hey rebecca
hey
and i'm thrilled to announce that
rebecca is joined our team um full time
and is our education community program
manager and as we know the architect
behind the adobe creative educator
course rebecca do you want to introduce
yourself really quickly before we dive
in yeah i'm really excited to work
wisely on this and get the graphic going
um been a teacher for
almost eight years and a designer before
that so i love working with creative
educators and coming up with ways to
make
learning come alive for students that's
kind of our big focus right now so i'm
going to go ahead and share my screen
we'll get started right now
sal this is our creative educator
challenge for this month we have a
student challenge
which is i am more than a score
and there is a template that students
can get started with and some videos to
get them started so they could do this
at their own pace and of course we
always start off with the teacher
challenge as well so that they can feel
comfortable with it before they get
started in the classroom so when we
click on that you get a template and
it's really fun because you just click
this remix this design
and it opens up for you in creative
cloud express and it's just a prompt to
get you started so you're not stuck with
this design or colors or anything else
so we're gonna first um you have to your
job right now sal is start thinking
about the words you're going to change
i happen to have an image of you so i'm
going to go ahead and change that out so
when you start in creative cloud express
it's always a good idea to click on the
artboard and then you can open up the
layers panel over here so i'm going to
click on one of these images of our
default image and i'm going to click
replace
and then i can upload images so i have
in my great american educators folder a
picture of you
there we go
and it will magically take away your
background um apply all the same filters
that we've done to this and then you are
magically inside
how many people have a great american
educators folder on there i think every
inch
i i we have i have them actually
categorized by centuries as well and
geographic locations so you did you you
made the cut there's only six in there
so nice i question your judgment but
let's go
i i i i stand behind my choices so this
is pink as you can see and maybe not
your favorite color maybe your favorite
color um what's really fun with this is
this is actually just a filter effect
that we can do so if you click down on
this um it's a duotone effect so it
gives us like really fun filter to it so
we can inside of creative cloud express
click on this and then i can use the
color picker tool which is like high
level photoshop kind of thing and change
york the color of your image to any
color that we have or of course i can go
through other kinds of pieces so i'm
actually going to find it from
the con logo which is this kind of green
here and i can change you and change the
color and then i can go through and
change and click on through my layers
change all of these other
graphics but as you were chatting i went
ahead and was tinkering
with that and have sort of started a
design i don't know how you feel about
it we can change it make it anything you
want to be
i i did go in and i took some
screenshots of some of the the
illustrations that are on the con
website which i really liked as kind of
a background and i was able to bring
that same kind of green color in as well
and i found the same color in here so
how do you feel about the design so far
i'm happy to make any changes that you
want i'm liking it maybe if we have more
than one color yeah more than one color
absolutely so we can actually this is
really fun because again i click on the
thing i go through maybe one of your
lighter colors we can maybe change your
center
you have another color you can so first
of all i'd ask you like what your
favorite colors are when we go over here
we can go through and choose on the more
there is a great color palette with tons
and tons of colors or we can pick
something
from anything any color that you want or
if you know the hex code off the top of
your head i'd be super impressed i don't
have a
favorite hex codes
but what's a good what's what's
i guess i guess like a pastel like a
warm like a like green and red are
complimentary right so um yeah this is
like
let's see what happens if i do this red
oh that's kind of fun
yeah yeah like that we could also make
it more of the orange
yeah i like that that's good awesome and
then if what's fun about this is we
brought that in there if we wanted to go
just a little bit darker i could click
on that and actually go in and just make
it a tiny bit darker or a little bit
more red
so we see your picture a little bit
better and if i don't i can go back and
just find that orange again and switch
you back out again
so that's the fun thing and you can do
the same thing to all of these shapes
and features we come in what's really
great is we have shapes over here and so
i just searched up a blob you can search
up anything so give me a word to search
up that you think we will not have a
shape for
is there like a uh is a shape word would
be the word no just anything viral i'll
go with spiral spiral
but now i'm worried about a small spiral
correctly because i'm live
trust me while i've been making
on khan academy videos the uh spelling i
i know how it is
writing words always life
so this is a no judgment zone
i i appreciate that this is our growth
mindset i'm learning how to spell the
word spiral so tons of spirals in here
um it's a fun thing we can kind of bring
those in and with what's great about
this i'm not sure if there's a specific
spiral that you like the best yeah some
of those are hypnotic i know they really
are they might be it might be too much
but we can always throw them in they'll
come in with a default color and then we
can change that we can change the size
of them we can rotate them we can move
them around we can even um change where
they are so i can go in you do i do have
this i can go color picker this this is
actually the hex code of your blue
just you know in the con colors so i
could throw this spiral back here and
actually just go and say drop it down to
the back so i could bring some other
kinds of colors in as well every time i
click on anything that that panel opens
up for properties but we should probably
focus on words so
any words that you have that's why i was
listening to you speak
um some things i brought in where if i
click on here you can go i heard you say
reflective and so i added that word and
right now we have you're more than a
scorer you're creative you're
collaborative you're courageous
reflective resilient in other words you
want to change your ad out for students
um
and this is these are things to tell
students to remind them yeah that
they're that they're more than just a
grade because or whatever happens on
that test like
that's really important and we learn so
much about that but we're so much bigger
than just that test
yeah i mean you know i meditate a lot
and i i meditate on you know i'm not the
body i am not the mind i am pure
awareness but maybe that's a little bit
too metaphysical oh i like it i do i do
find it very
liberating
even this mind that is throwing out all
these crazy thoughts that's not quite me
i'm the observer of the mind how about
you are more than a mind
yeah
or yeah
even i mean it's it's getting at a level
you know
but
you know you you are awareness so we
have two different you're a pure
awareness you are the awareness
we can turn this into it we have a
spiral we're almost like at a labyrinth
then we have a meditation point yeah you
might have to throw a big ohm symbol
there
um
we have i also heard you say being um
about the creative process being like an
inspired learner inspired by your
surroundings so i added that in artist
thinker scholar supportive yeah
determined persistent yeah i don't know
if there's about but i always tell
young people i i remind older people um
all the time like like you know we get
so i know you can help me on the right
word but like we get so caught up with
the mundane day-to-day that stresses us
out but we like lose sight of the fact
that we're like in like we're aware in
this universe that is for the most part
a mystery
and like just the wonder of being able
to explore it so maybe you're an
explorer
you know the wonder you're an explorer
of the wonder of the cosmos of of
reality itself like you know every one
of us it's like an adventure and we
forget it while we're doing our taxes
and you know trying to turn in
tomorrow's assignment
was that explorer of the wonder of the
cosmos is that right yeah why not i love
it
i think it might have gotten a little
bit big but that's okay we have all
these what's so fun about this is that
we've done this and thousands of
educators have already done this and
actually a few thousand students have
already done this to just launch for
them on monday and it's so beautiful to
see just with a couple of prompts how
everyone's um response to this is so
unique and they've changed you know they
they change the words how they think
about themselves and how they think
about their students and so that's what
we're really trying to do with these
challenges is to give just enough that
people take it and make it completely
uniquely and beautifully their own so we
could spend more minutes on this and i
know that we're kind of we're probably
at time but um i it was so great to hear
you speak and um i'll tinker with this a
little bit more and then and send this
on over to you but uh thanks so much for
creating with us today and creative
cloud express thank you this is a lot of
fun
well thank you sal and rebecca and ben
for joining us today and i'm just going
to put a quick reminder here um so we'd
love for you to create your own uh
graphic and we'll be sharing out sals
later for inspiration um but if you go
to the link below and adobe.ly edu april
stpg and we put that in the chat as well
you can create your own image and then
we'd love for you to share that
with the hashtag adobe edu creative so
that we see all of the no matter what
time zone you're in you can go ahead and
post your image in there
um but before we sign off today a big
thank you again to sal to ben to rebecca
um and quick um closing comments sal for
those who want to stay in touch with
khan academy stay in touch with you what
are the best um social channels or
website uh to check out yeah we we have
uh both i um
i think it's sal khan academy uh and
then we have khan academy on all the
major social channels twitter instagram
facebook uh linkedin i've gotten more
active actually have a tick tock look
for me there too
our neighbors convinced me to get on
tick-tock
but no this was this was this is really
fun and i i do think i agree with then
this is fundamental you know creativity
is underpins everything
well be sure to check the out those
social channels and that tick tock
sounds like a lot of fun
um and ben um in terms of your social
channels i see your your handle anything
else you want to share with education
yeah i i'm not young or cool enough for
sal to have tick tock so um you can find
me you can find me at benford or online
at walter.com and i love hearing from
everybody
thank you and rebecca
oh i'm just excited to see and learn how
to dance for missal
on the tick tock panel that's that i
that's that's how i can't get anything
else out of it i'm gonna learn all the
new dances
well thank you all again for joining us
and be sure to use the hashtag adobe edu
creative in your takeaways from today uh
but have a wonderful rest of your week
we look forward to seeing all of your
images and continuing to inspire
creative confidence in all of your
students
we'll see you next month for our next
live stream bye everyone